so I know you've made some short films
before you made a few of your features
how much money did you have to make your
first film for to consider a real movie
because you know there's like these
litmus tests like oh well that's not a
real movie it's only you know eight
thousand or whatever but at some point
at what point did you say this is a this
is a real movie here and what was the
budget yeah I think that's an
interesting question because a lot of
people do put these litmus tests on what
it means to make a real movie and I
think it's because it's a real
movie the second that people are
watching it and the second that people
are writing about it and I think that is
actually the second and most key
component especially in the digital era
when you have YouTube and Vimeo and all
these digital platforms that aren't
necessarily monetized if you make a
short film that someone writes about and
I mean film journalists bloggers all
these various things I think then you've
made a real film it has nothing to do
with money because your career is about
creating things and and evolving as an
artist to tell stories that hopefully
people are going to access and enjoy but
if they don't know that you're making
something then you're not making a real
film because it's not for an audience
it's then for yourself so for me the
litmus test always has to do with when
people respond to it and the first thing
that I did where I really had some
people respond was a short film that I
made for less than $1000 called the
carwash with an actress named Edith IV
and it was a really neat experience I
just finished directing a piece in
college for the Golden Age about the
Golden Age of Radio for the National
Association of Broadcasters education
wing in Vegas and I had gone over the
course of a semester while I was in
college full time student Monday through
Thursday taking classes Friday Saturday
Sunday traveling around the country
interviewing these folks on the weekends
it was strenuous it was awful and it was
a very difficult eight weeks but over
the course of that period I met Edith
who had just finished the Curious Case
of Benjamin Button with David Fincher
and I had been writing this screenplay
because I wanted to make a short
narrative and I thought that Dixie
Carter was gonna play the lead because I
had worked with her on the first film I
ever produced but she had just passed
away and so once I met Edith for this
documentary that we were making I said
you know she's actually perfect for this
role and I sent her the screenplay
terrified because she had just worked
with David Fincher and here are my lowly
college student and she read the
screenplay and sent me a message back
and said you know I can't believe that
anyone under 55 wrote this material and
I will do it for free and I was
mind-boggled by it now of course I did
not have her do it for free I did a sag
minimum because I think that's ethical
paid her a hundred dollars for two days
and we made the film and it went to
festivals people liked it it's got a lot
of views online and that would I would
say be my first legitimate film but the
films I made afterwards did end up
getting more press and such but I think
that's the progression you make
you